oh do you know this about koreans is
this a true thing where they take a
funeral photo
um like a funeral portrait before they
die
like you were saying you were talking as
if i was passed away and deceased right
would you guys be into that bobby wood
bobby's took some pictures when his dad
passed away
no no no like you take like you know
that you're let's say you're in your 80s
and you're coming to the end of your
life yeah
and so you go into a studio and you take
a funeral portrait with your family and
all your
um god children you know what i would
like holding you up like you're laying
in their arms like a cross you're not
dying yet
but it's your last final regal portrait
of your life
no i would do one of those 3d mugs or
statues
you do at the mall now so you go into it
you know they have that now at malls
it costs thousands of dollars but i
would like to be a mug
like a coffee mug with my family you
could get dermy too they had a guy by us
when i was growing up who had been
who'd had a family member taxidermied
fully
that's what i want just mount it on
someone's wall but i get to choose
my pose yeah that's very yeah
this guy had been uh they had their
uncle it was he was doing like
yeah yeah what did you do like like
it was like a yoga pose like it looked
like he was doing a
like yeah like a no like a prayer or
like he was gonna do
like he was doing part of patty cake you
know yeah yeah but he and they caught
him like right like that but
i remember they had him they had a they
had a human man taxidermied
i would probably do a pose where it's
like i was in a ufc fight
okay and somebody gut punched me and so
i'm like
gonna be like one leg on the ground yeah
and i'm flying back
right and like this yeah that'd be cool
in action
because i want people to know that i was
like you know it wouldn't be true it'd
be lying right but i was that you were
in action but i was in action you know
when i died if you were terminally ill
would you
want a funeral before or after you die
oh i think this is really this is a
really amazing thing you're saying and
i'm glad we're listening to you
um all right you already got one are you
trying to get two titties i would say
yeah
you're trying to get two you're trying
to get two no i'm not you creep
i'm happy with one man yeah okay
i just want something the cat can play
with in the living room yeah
um no but what if we start getting so
like into ourselves as humans that we
start having our funerals before
we die that's what she was asking yeah i
could see that because some people do
that now
wow really yeah yeah i think that that
movie would uh nicholas cage the
weatherman
he does that right with his father or
something like that where they do
a live funeral when the person is still
living so that you get to hear
what everyone is what you know your
whole family really truly thinks of you
from their heart
but the problem is that you do the
[ __ ] funeral before
and then what if you don't die right
away yeah and then six months later
you're out of starbucks
and some dude that was at your funeral
sees you yeah and they're like
you're not dead yet yeah yeah some guy
banged your sister after your funeral
you're like hey what are you doing here
yeah
you're the kind of guy that tries to
bang at somebody's funeral yeah sicko
also i don't want to also a sicko boy
yes sicko man yeah i also don't want my
funeral before because what if no one
shows up
oh no no no because if i died right
stevie's going to freaking show up dude
she's going to go i know but do
i want life if i'm in town i'm going to
go dude people are going to go if you're
in town
all right all right that's a good
question i don't know what my schedule
is i understand that but
i'm going to ask you right right now
yeah
what and i want you the honest [ __ ]
answer okay because we're pros right
yeah okay i want honest answers from you
okay
so what would you cancel right
mm-hmm to go to my funeral oh i'd
definitely cancel my own wedding if i
had if i was freaking getting married
okay that's big what about this would
you would you cancel
let's say you sold out but i can't small
wedding for probably almost anything
else
yeah that's all right that's why i
[ __ ] brushed my ass back weddings
oh yeah but let's say you sold out like
a 20 000 seat venue
but it lands on the same day as my
funeral would you cancel that
be honest i couldn't man and i don't
think you'd want me to that's why i
wouldn't
i think you'd want me to be there he'd
want you to i'd want you to
what if i got a live stream of you in
your casket to open up
wow i'll make you a deal okay i'm the
closing
oh you really record a set no i wanna
just do the live stream
of my casket at the end when he's
getting a standing ovation
just boom yeah you put it on the monitor
so that i could
you know when i'm flying up to heaven
i'm flying and i can see it and i'm
getting a standing oh that'd be [ __ ]
cool
it'd be cool yeah yeah i could do that
man i'll do that for you would you
cancel um
no i have one i have one yeah go ahead
uh pourier khabib rematch his retirement
fight
for the championship you're sitting
front row you know what
you're cornering him at this point bobby
dies
what do you do just probably wish bobby
was there with me you know
[Laughter]
but like in a loving way man i would and
i'd bring that tit with me for good luck
and i put it at the bottom of the ice
bucket of pourier's ice bucket yeah
let's do a softball one let's do a
softball one um
let's see you met let's see you met a
girl
dude are we gonna is somebody at least
going to wash my hair
i'm in here
we're a popular [ __ ] barber shop my
friend yeah i know you didn't make an
appointment you didn't make an
appointment
i'm just saying man let's get it let's
cut to the trim so you went to vegas and
you saw
the fight now what i mean so polya
did you see the fight oh my god crazy we
saw the fight